look at this nonsense article that
actually confuses people and millions of
people took advantage of this
if you've stayed put out your company
during the great resignation you're
paying a price for your loyalty insider
may 24th over the past year the red hot
job market has forced employers to dole
out huge paychecks to lure new
candidates and that's created a deep
divide between the rookies and the
veterans at the companies across the u.s
labor iq compensation data provider
estimates that salaries for new hires
are seven percent higher on average and
a medium pay for people already employed
in similar positions for many in-demand
occupants occupations across tech and
finance the disparity is in double
digits in the great resignation
long-time employees the ones who have
stuck around through good times and bad
times are paying a secret tax for their
loyalty i disagree here's why let me
tell you what's about to happen for
those who abused
that uh uh going to their bosses and
saying you know such and such recruiter
called me i have another opportunity to
work at this company and they're going
to pay me more money than you are and
i'm going to take the job and you
bullied your employer
when it comes time
that the market correction takes place
and silicon valley announces the freeze
that they have now on hiring
when it comes time that you see these
companies letting go of
4 000 employees
10 000 employees wait till you see the
firing and the layoffs banks are about
to announce the next three six 12 months
just just brace for impact where these
big companies that gave you that bonus
that you went to them wait till they
fire you know who that employee is going
to call they're going to call back that
employer that they left and say i made a
big mistake leaving i'd love to come
back you know i went and i realized i
don't want to be part and they're going
to create their own skit story i
realized i'm not a large corporation
person but this experience made me
appreciate you even more it's like when
a guy leaves a girl and goes with
another girl doesn't work out and say
she made me love you even more if it
wasn't for her my love for you wouldn't
have grown to the levels it has today
are you reading my text message i'll
just have so much
we gotta get together right now oh my
god i'm so glad she trained you to love
me even more right whatever that may be
she takes him back yeah if exactly if
if you
were loyal during that time if you were
loyal during that time
and you did what you did
that ceo that boss of yours values you
believe me privately they're sitting
there making a list of people that they
can count on and you're on it
and this may not be a bad time to have
the following conversation here's the
conversation on how to have
hey boss
listen uh i believe in what you're doing
i believe in the company i believe in
your leadership i just want to let you
know i'm here long term i would like to
be considered for the following i think
you value loyalty i've shown you i'm
loyal to you during good and bad times
if there is a way for me to be
considered for another position higher
up let me know what i'd like to do but
i'd like to be able to fight for a race
and a promotion i don't want to go
anywhere i love the company i want to be
able to take this company to the next
level i appreciate your style of
leadership tell me what i need to do i'd
like to have that kind of a conversation
with you if you're open to it okay great
but that's the approach versus i got two
offers here the recruiter i didn't reach
out i was i didn't have my resume out
there but they somehow found me and and
they're offering me twenty eight
thousand dollars more if you can give me
that raise i will because i wanna stay
with you i wanna stay with you but if
you do that i'll stay with you those
people who were that opportunistic and
adam i understand those people who are
opportunistic
they're not going to like life the next
12 to 24 months it's going to be hit so
hard because when you go all of a sudden
be paid 120 and you're not worth 120
you're an 82 000 year person yep but
your lifestyle went to 120 and now the
market fires you and now you got to go
from 120 and there's not an 82 000 of
your job that you're willing to accept a
68 000 of your job a bankruptcy's around
the corner a repo is around the corner
and life's going to get messy and now
you have to get started with a resume
that's going to show over a five year
period you got five jobs and that's not
a good resume because employers look at
resumes to see if you stay with
companies or you go resume shop and
nobody likes somebody that's been around
the block in the job market people don't
like that tom now you get to work from
home you're unemployed from the couch
i feel for the business owners small
business owners medium sized business
owners right now there's such a labor
shortage in a lot of different
industries and you know there the talent
is tough to find my sister and i have
our own company and it's incredibly
difficult and they ultimately are the
ones who have to pay the price you know
i don't say that i don't think they need
nowhere
no but yeah people look at things in
such a short-term way i don't mean to
throw millennials under the bus as well
but you should be paid what you're worth
but also there's a there is something to
say about experience and staying with a
company that you believe in and the
long-term growth potential there than
just shopping around and getting paid
that in a short-term way
you you hit the nail on the head what
the difference between a short-term and
a long-term perspective like i just had
my 15-year anniversary at
my firm my financial firm that i worked
for it's crazy 15 years
and i've been offered jobs left and
right over the last decade or so left
and right
and do i entertain the conversation sure
but at the end of the day i'm very loyal
and i've built in very uh good
situation in my job but
i think you're absolutely right short
term yeah maybe an extra 20 grand so it
does sound good
but when uh what's that when the tide
rolls back out you know you're left
naked whatever that is when you're if
you're skinny dipping that's what's
going to happen is essentially what
you're saying out there yeah i mean by
the way
how was your last month
uh best month i've had in 15 years yeah
i had a great month yeah yeah but but
lunch is on me guys
that's not gonna happen because the ten
dollars you still haven't paid the guys
so that's not going to happen right
servant leaders good business people
good uh ceos good leaders do value good
employees and that loyalty so you're
that's what people need to think about
and you think about deeper things right
so people out there looking for a new
job go ahead and rewind the last few
minutes and hear what pat had to say
you're funny we are hiring though if you
are looking for a job we're aggressively
hiring right now so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you